[Musique]
bonsoir à vous merci d'être venu si
nombreux en ce lendemain du 2è tour des
législatives comme vous le savez euh 20
candidats ver dimanche 1 juin
197 députés vert et apparentés sont élus
les écologistes entrent au Parlement
Dominique VO est nommé à la tête d'un
grand ministère de l'Aménagement du
Territoire et de l'Environnement une
page vient d'être tournée celle de
l'histoire de la génération
verte en 30 ans le mouvement est entré
dans l'AG mure de 1968 à 1981 sous la
houlette de René Dumont et de Briss
laonde le mouvement s'organise et
témoigne de 1981 à 1997 partagé entre
ses leaders il vit ses heures de gloire
et de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
misère 5 an
22s8
député des
ver Jean Carlier 75 ans 43 ans en 68
journaliste bris lalond 51 ans 22 ans 68
ancien ministre et président de
Génération
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Écologie le mouvement écologiste Françis
est
[Musique]
né quelques années après
68 mais mais c'est vrai que à sa source
il y a un courant de l'écologie qui
vient de 68 c'était le
courant disons spontané des jeunes qui
voulaient changer de vie voilà ce sont
les jeunes qui sont éduqués c'est
l'arrivée des 30es glorieuses on
consomme on découvre la télévision le
monde entier c'est l'époque où l'Europe
arrive enfin et donc toute cette
génération ne se retrouve pas dans les
partis politiques qui sont dominants à
l'époque en mai 68 j'étais président de
la Corporation des étudiants en sciences
à l'Université de Rennes à l'UNEF et
puis est arrivé 68 avec des discussions
passionnées passionnantes mais en même
temps stérile à mon avis du point de vue
disons de la créativité politique qui
vouit faire autre chose quand éclatent
les événements de Mai 68 if cocher est
en DEA de sciences dans les
amphithéâtres il retrouve ceux qui
mettent en question le progrès
scientifique à quoi bon ce progrès si
l'on vit plus mal si les déséquilibres
nord- sudud s'accentuent qui décide du
progrès pour
qui
est-ce que les choix scientifiques les
choix de recherche sont des choix hors
du temps ou bien est-ce qu'il sont
dictés en fait par des considérations
stratégiques ou industrielle je pense
qu'ils le sont bien entendu que les
scientifiques ont une responsabilité
alors c'est un peu ça qui m'a fait
découvrir l'écologie politique aussi en
dehors d'une militance de terrain disons
dans les associations de protection de
la nature c'est aussi le questionnement
à travers la science qu'est-ce que la
société nous impose comme choix que ça
soit dans la science ça soit dans
l'économie que ça soit dans les
transports ou bien dans dans la
politique énergétique
alors 68 est une espèce de première
crise et ça n'apparaît que quelques
années plus tard lorsque ce courant de
68 qui voulait changer la vie qui
voulait quoi tout vouit tout rencontre
d'autres d'autres combats d'autres
luttes découvr l'écologie bris Lalonde
fils d'un riche TRAPIER et d'origine
écais par sa mère elle lui a appris le
nom des plantes et l'amour des animaux
en hippocagne à Louis le Grand il est
formé aux lettres classiques mais il
rêve d'archéologie et de la vraie vie en
face à la Sorbonne où il va se battre
contre la langue de bois gauchiste
alors moi j'ai étis président de la
Sorbonne des étudiants de la Sorbonne en
68 et
j'été furieux contre les groupes muscul
trist Maoist tous ces gensl qui avaient
un vocabulaire compliqué il voulit
absolument nous
chapoter jours sois toujours les mêmes
qui dirigent les
débats
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une dizaine
d'arragés mais qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui
d'une prise de conscience grandissante
dans tout le mouvement
étudiant avec mai 68 sesquissent les
premières critiques de la société de
consommation un certain type de
développement est mis en cause quelques
années plus tard les idées d'ivanilic
traverseront l'Atlantique renforçant
l'opinion de ceux qui mettent en
question l'école la marchandise
l'impression que le taux de croissance
engendre de la richesse il prône une
utopie où celui qui consomme moins et
plus heureux il rejoint ainsi les idées
du Club de Rome qui ne cessent
d'annoncer le prochain épuisement des
ressources mais en attendant c'est à la
voiture gadget et symbole que s'en prend
la
jeunesse et puis j'étais un cycliste
c'estàdire que je vivais à Paris je
faisais de la bicyclette je me déplaçais
la bicyclette et j'ai rencontré par
hasard une association qui venait de se
créer en 70 enfin donc 2 ans après M 68
qui s'appelit les Amis de la Terre
c'était un avocat américain et un
journaliste français qui venait de faire
le tour du monde en bateau qui avait
rencontrer les Américains en Californie
c'est en 1971 qu'alin Hervé journaliste
aventurier fonde Les Amis de la Terre
filiale française de friendend of the
earth peu intéressé par la conduite
d'une organisation qui va structurer le
mouvement politique il en laisse les
reenes au mathématicien pierre Samuel
quelques temps plus tard en émergera la
branche française de
greenpce c'était une très grande
effervescence d'abord parce que c'était
un terrain totalement nouveau totalement
neuf passionnant une découverte
magnifique c'était la découverte aussi
du grand monde l'Amérique puisque ces
thèmes nous venent directement de
Californie c'était San Francisco C club
Amis de la Terre tout ça c'est San
Francisco et quelques années plus tard
Vancouver donc vraiment le Pacifique
c'estàd Greenpeace tous ces thèmes
étaient totalement nouveau donc on les
apprenait on était passionné et on a
essayait donc de de très exactement en
France de mélanger de de mélanger la
tradition M68 la tradition politique
française militante l'activisme avec
tout d'un coup ce ces thèmes qui
venaient de de directement de de
Californie et je ne pouvais pas
m'empêcher de penser que tous ces
écologistes on les appelait pas comme ça
à l'époque mais enfin c'est ces gens
manquaient totalement de savoir-faire
militant et qu'il leur fallait
absolument des des ouvriers de la
[Musique]
Révolution j'ai commencé à à militer et
à m'engager à l'âge de 17 ans en 1973
c'est aux Amis de la Terre comme
beaucoup de jeunes de l'époque qui ont
entre disons je pense entre 15 et 20 ans
qui n'ont pas vécu 68 qu' l'ont vécu par
procuration qui ne pouvaient pas vu leur
âge 11 12 ans 13 ans être dans la rue et
heureusement pour eux c'était quand même
un peu dangereux qu' se disent tiens je
vis moi aussi quelque chose de réel et
non pas de théorique mais de vraiment
pratique je crois que je tombe en même
temps dans dans un grand mouvement je
suis pour les Indiens contre les cowboys
c'est c'est c'est très clair et le choix
a été vite fait peut-être familial mais
aussi parce que je crois que comme
beaucoup de gamins on est pour les
Indiens quoi même si après on apprend à
aimer les les cowboil aussi les
premières batailles ont été en effet sur
le cadre de ville l'idée de d'appeler
les gens à bicyclette contre les voies
express rive gauche on voulait mettre
une autoroute au centre de Paris
Pompidou disait il fallait adapter Paris
à l'automobile et donc ça a été tout de
suite mais certainement pas il faut
faire le contraire il ne faut surtout
pas défigurer Paris l'endroit où l'on
vit et ça a été la découverte de tout
cela
[Musique]
les manifestations en vélo vont rythmer
les débuts de l'écologie
1971 72 76 elle rassemble des milliers
de personnes à Paris elle symbolise le
refus de la voiture mais aussi de
nouvelle lutte mais bon Paris est à nous
pour les
paris quand je dis Paris est à nous je
pense que je pense toujours pareil à la
même manière c'est que les grandes
villes sont à nous c'est on on est en
train de de de de prendre les trottoir
l'espace urbain tel qu'il est et je
crois que là il y a une naissance forte
de de ce qu'on de ce qui devient après
au fur à mesure l'écologie urbaine un
courant que médias et institutions
mettront un peu de temps à reconnaître
dont sont issus par exemple Pierre radan
ou guyascet qui réclame une nouvelle
organisation de la vie en ville une
aspiration au mieux
vivre mieux identifier un autre courant
irrigue la nébuleuse il s'agit des
protecteurs de la nature en 1967
l'accident du toré canyon qui touche la
Bretagne va rapprocher écolo des villes
et des champs les marin noires ne sont
plus un simple problème local il faut
pour les gérer une organisation
nationale et même internationale en 1969
la puissante fédération de protection de
la nature voit le jour faisant connaître
en France l'ouvrage de Rachel Carlson le
printemps silencieux c'est un cri
d'alarme volontiers catastrophiste ces
thèmes sont repris par les associations
régionales françaises de l'Alsace à
l'Auvergne il faut revenir à mes
origines
auvergnat je suis un enfant du pu d'Ô et
et je pense que je veux dire que quand
on avait envie de voir le temps c'est
pas la radio qu'on écoutait on regardait
le pu d'ome pour voir quel temps il
ferait et cetera et et j'ai vu
comment petit à petit la campagne
partait un peu quoi les vignes ont perdu
une rangée parce que c'était trop long à
travailler et ainsi de suite quoi qu et
donc je voulais qu' garder ça quoi
instinctivement voilà quand on a dit
sous les pavé la plage moi j'ai d sous
la plage la terre donc j'étais pas sur
la même longueur d'onde que que les gens
de mes 68 et j'ai même dit plus tard
quand j'ai vu qu'ils étaient dans la
détresse j'ai dit les orphelins de mes
68 ont sauté dans le train de l'écologie
parce qu'ils sont dit on va tout même
aller là-dedans c'est un peu ça nous
ressemble un peu quand même voilà la
presse a pris le relais du mouvement le
catastrophisme se vend bien et puis en
1969 Armstrong a marché sur la Lune
chacun découvre alors les limites du
vaisseau terre les pionniers
journalistes sont nombreux un ti de
journaliste un ti d'infirmière un ti de
prof on pourrait dire ça comme
ça il y a mais parce que c'est quoi
journaliste on devient journaliste quand
on a envie d'écrire quand on a envie
d'exprimer ma conception c'est de de
journaliste c'est de d'écouter les gens
et de répercuter ce que disent des gens
le plus
non pas le plus fidèlement possible au
niveau strict du terme mais au niveau du
fond ne jamais trahir les gens que j'ai
que j'ai que j'ai écouté que j'ai
entendu ainsi m 68 a révélé l'importance
de la presse le 4è pouvoir du dénoncé
est à prendre la jeune génération se
lance dans sa conquête déjà existe une
chronique celle de Jean Carlier qui dès
67 mobilise la France pour sauver la
Vanoise Jean RTL il fait il a lancé les
années fin des années
60 66 67 les les premières rubriques
environnementales sur RTL Grosse Radio
hein c'est la plus grosse radio
française ça c'est les années 6 67 68 69
et il y a les années aussi euh fin début
d' années 70 où euh les la conception
environnementale commence à à percer
dans dans le monde politique de l'époque
c'est la création du ministère de
l'Environnement 70 71 et à la fois en
même temps ce ce fond c'est il y a cette
émission à la télévision qui apparaît
qui qui s'appelle la France des figurés
la France des figurés c'était tous les
dimanches à 17h et à l'époque avec deux
chaînes hein et on faisait 60 % du
marché c'était l'émission la plus suivie
et la plus regarder de la télé elle
avait un impact absolument considérable
quand je descendais dans un village euh
avec la France des figurés je me
souviens du maire de cour qui était
coocatrix à ce moment-là qui dit si la
France dé figurer débarqu je lâche les
chiens gênis hein souvens que P Pigou
avait dit la France des figurés c'est
une très mauvaise image pour la
France parallèlement à la grande presse
les écologistes vont lancer leur propre
titre Le Sauvage créé par Alain Hervé
est lié au groupe du Nouvel Observateur
fait par des pros il dispose d'un budget
conséquent ce qui n'est pas le cas du
journal écologie puis un journal qu'
faut pas qu'on peut pas oublier celui de
Jean-Luc burgander qui s'appelait
écologie he écologie info qui est quand
même un historique de l'écologie
politique et qui met euh toute sa vie
l'ensemble de ses fonds et héritages de
terroir hein et perd même ses baraques
d'héritage et autres pour tenir ce
journal autre héritage l'enfant de
Charlie hebbdo la gueule ouverte comme
son nom l'indique c'était un journal
pour gueuler euh avant la fin du monde
quoi on voulait on voulait bien crever
mais la gueule ouverte c'était ça le
l'idée du je me rappelle que on a
cherché ce titre pendant des jours et
des
jours
c'est Fournier il a abandonné le dessin
il a voulu faire un journal avec
l'argent de de Charlie Hebdo on a il a
il a pu lancer la gueule ouverte qui
était un mensuel au
début et il réser était un
écolo et lui lui il apportait le des
idées positives des alternatives lui il
a fait vraiment un peu Léonard de
Vinc chaque semaine il racontait ses
brioles
sur l'énergie solaire c'était
formidable on s'est aperçu très vite
quand même
que c'était difficile de vendre un
journal
qui qui se plaignait tout le temps quoi
qui qui trouvait que tout allit
mal je pense que maintenant il y a il y
a de l'écologie un peu dans tous les
journaux tu vois mais justement emballé
dans des belles images ce que tu vois 16
pages ou 24 pages uniquement pour dire
là ça va pas là ça va pas là c'est la
merde là on va crever je crois que c'est
trop pour les gens on retrouve dans dans
dans la gueule ouverte donc sur sur
plusieurs équipes alors Arthur
évidemment qui qui est un des grands
noms Isabelle Cabu Bruno Civel Marc
tivol hélè criet qui qui fait ses
premières âmes environnementales Michel
guerbrant et d'autres comme ça qui qui
soit font un passage passe à Libération
ou pass à d'autrre titre ou même arrête
journalisme soit ça soit régulièrement
on les retrouve on les retrouve
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui donc tout ceci est né en
même moment et puis une une question
ensuite stratégique euh au fond tout ça
c'est l'écologieque comment est-ce que
l'on peut faire triomfer l'écologie
comment est-ce que l'on peut faire
comprendre ce qui se passe et nous avons
hésité entre la voiture et les centrales
nucléaires finalement le c'est le
nucléaire qui a structuré
oui c'est le nucléaire oui parce que
finalement c'était moins dilué que
l'automobile c'était elles étaient pas
construite c'est c'était en quelque
sorte le gouvernement qui nous offrait
le champ de
bataille profondément imprégné de l'idée
qu'ils vont changer la société les
écologistes s'attaquent au symbole de
l'État leur premier combat rassembleur
va être la défense du plateau du Larzac
l'armée y a un projet d'extension du
camp militaire
des moutons contre des T le décor est
planté et les paysans du Larzac verront
débarquer plus de 60000
Urb autre principe fédérateur la lutte
antinucléaire de 1971 où un millier de
personn manifeste à Fessenheim jusqu'à
Malville en 1977 où ils seront plus de
60000 il se retrouveve au bget à
Graveline dans le Nord et sur les landes
de
plogof plog restera site de la dernière
résistance d'année en année l'opposition
s'amplifie les marins pêcheurs et les
Bretonnes en coiffe rejoignent les
écolos un nouveau mouvement social a vu
le jour qui veut décider de sa manière
de vivre de sa santé de son
[Musique]
progrès d'un autre point de vue il y
avait des échéances électorales et les
Amis de la Terre qui avaient cette
double faculté d'être à la fois très
environnementaliste très associatif y
compris à l'chant internationale mais
aussi engagé au moins localement voire
même nationalement dans les élections on
fait que Ben pour la première fois en 74
à cette élection présidentielle là où il
y a eu d'ailleurs GIS cardestin qui a
été élu et bien la première candidature
vraiment représentative de l'écologie
politique cette fois-ci celle de René
Dumont qui certes a fait un score
médiocre mais qui du point de vue
symbolique a lancé en fait l'écologie
politique en France donc on a soutenu
René Dumont on a participé à
quelques-unes de ses réunions sur la
péniche qui lui tenait lieu disons de
local de campagne
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu penses de René Dumont
mais j'ai dit ce serait très bien
seulement il est jamais là mais
justement il revient d'Alger demain
après-midi et je dis ce serait très bien
dans la mesure où il n'est plus
seulement agronome il est aussi devenu
écologiste en publiant l'année
précédente l'utopie ou la mort il a viré
sa cuti il est un peu vert sur les bords
maintenant donc on peut ben allez-y
alors mais tu voudrais pas venir ça
ferait plus sérieux mend dit puis en
plus nous on a qu'une de chevaux dit au
contraire moi j'ai pas de voiture mais
vous avec une de chevaux vous allez lui
plaire beaucoup n é quelquesuns en deux
chevaux en de chevau je lui pose la
question je ne sais pas comment je
t'appel d'ailleurs est-ce que vous
accepteriez d'être notre candidat je
pense que tu vas toutoyer quand même bon
alors je ne me souviens plus dans avec
les années qui passent et tu as demandé
un jour de réflexion seulement 24 heur
de réflexion probablement c'est toute
une équipe de jeunes C écologistes en
grande majorité et probement qu' avaent
besoin d'avoir un sens de respectabilité
pour ça il fallait un ancien mais
évidemment un ancien d'abord qui sache
parler à la télévision ENF il faut être
à l'aise devant les étranges lucernes on
savait que le propriétaire des bateau
mouches du Pallem luttait contre la
construction d'une route sur berge sur
la rive gauche et par conséquent avait
comme allier les écologistes alors à ce
moment-là nous somm all trouver et il
nous a offert un bateau de réforme il
bateau qui sert à rien je l'ofre pour la
durée de la campagne
électorale si au départ une grande
majorité de militants est opposé à la
création d'un parti l'idée de la
candidature de René Dumont fait
consensus ingénieur agronome il s'est
fait connaître du grand public par son
bestseller l'Afrique et mal parti avec
son pullau vert rouge un verre d'eau à
la main il fait une campagne médiatique
et peu coûteuse 5000 jours pour sauver
la planète comme ça a été écrit il y a 2
ans il nous reste plus 5000 jours hein
les autres candidats de la gaucheextrême
gauche les candidats marxistes par
exemple il faut dominer la nature pour
l'exploiter au profit de l'homme nous il
faut respecter la nature la protégé pour
qu'elle garde son potentiel de
production et je dis c'est pas au niveau
de vie c'est un niveau de
gaspillage la la façon dont il parle des
choses est un est une concept est un
concept complètement inhabituel en
France c'est un concept non
productiviste au sens fort du terme
c'estàd que il parle de l'eau il parle
de l'énergie il parle des choses qui
sont il a sa pomme là il a son verre
d'eau puis dit tout ça ça coûte cher et
ça n'est pas des biens qui sont des
biens qu'on pourra avoir tout le temps
de manière
incommensurable René Dumont obtient 1,35
% des voix c'est peu mais c'est le
premier score d'une nouvelle formation
qui va aller en s'affirmant c'est en
tout cas le score exact qui sépare les
deux candidats restés en LCE au second
tour giscar et mitteran après le le
mouvement écolo se retrouve en 74 juste
après s la campagne présidentielle à
Montargis il y a 3000 personnes qui se
retrouvent et qui n'arrivent pas à se
mettre d'accord parce que tous les
courants à la fois libertaire les
courants de droite les courants de
gauche se retrouve là et personne ne
veut conceptualiser et structurer le
mouvement de manière
forte après la candidature de René
Dumont le mouvement va s'organiser les
échéances électorales sont nombreuses et
les SCOR s'affirment pour chaque
échéance le mouvement se retrouve et
décide de se donner à non créant ce que
les militants baptisent des
organisations biodégradables les débats
qui agitent la mouvance ne sont pas
seulement des problèmes de personnes
mais bien le fait de trouver une
identité à ce nouveau courant
[Musique]
politique plusieurs événements cimentent
et consolident l'organisation le projet
de construction du surgénérateur à CRESS
Malville et le naufrage de la mokocadis
sur le front du mieux vivre le mouvement
se donne de nouveaux outils il remplace
la grève par le boycott l'action directe
la manifestation pacifique est ludique à
destination des médias il remplace les
syndicats par des associations de
défense de la nature ou du consommateur
dont la plupart ont une branche
internationale nous avons appelé au
boycotte pour obtenir de cette compagnie
qu'elle s'engage à verser des indemnités
complémentaires aux victimes de la
catastrophe puisqu'on estime
généralement que les assurances ne
couvriront que la moitié à peine des
dommages occasionné un autre événement
va marquer durablement le jeune
mouvement alors qu'en 1976 le
rassemblement contre super phéniix à
Malville s'était déroulé de manière
pacifique celui du 31 juillet 1977
s'annonce très mal des groupes
gauchistes durs ont rejoint les écolos
l'État a interdit la manifestation 40000
personnes se retrouvent prises dans une
véritable opération militaire qui
coûtera la vie à Vital Michalon le ton
change l'écologie s'oppose désormais à
l'état et puis il a Briss la Londes qui
se présente à des cantonales partieles
et il lance vraiment une conception du
mouvement écolopolitique que certains
que lui d'ailleurs a appelé libéral
libertaire une idée qui se traduit par
de l'Alliance à la carte et qui va semer
de l'incrédulité l'idée de former un
parti reprend de la force le MEP
mouvement d'écologie politique voit le
jour c'est un embryon de parti outre les
Alsaciens on y retrouve Philippe Le
Breton universitaire liyonnais qui
s'oppose à brislalonde pour décider de
qui sera candidat au présidentiel en
1981 des primaires ont lieu à Lyon pour
la dernière fois le mouvement écologiste
va partir uni derrière le candidat bris
Lalonde la difficulté a BR Lalonde c'est
que il ne veut pas constituer un
mouvement durable d'écologie politique
structuré et en plus il c'est lui qui
lance contrairement à ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui et ce qu'on peut penser qui
lance cette idée de ni droite ni gauche
que l'écologie est audessus de tout ça
ou ailleurs par rapport à tout c'est
faut changer la politique est-ce que
c'est sérieux finalement que des
étatmajors décident les candidats puis
que ceuxci se promèent partout en disant
voilà le programme vter pour moi la
politique de nos jours consiste d'abord
à aller écouter les Français et à
trouver parmi eux ceux qui ont déjà
proposé des solutions il voulait que on
se tourne vers le PSU qu'on se tourne
vers le Parti radical que si et cetera
c'est donc ça qui m'avait
froissé et et j'avais un peu pris de
recul avec ces mouvements là j'avais
beaucoup insisté auprès de couo pour
qu'il soit le candidat dernier doute
dernier sousbrosau dernière tentative
mais Coustau dira non il craint un score
trop modeste en rassemblant 3,35 % des
suffrages et plus d'un million de voix
laalonde fait un bon score entre les
deux tour une négociation a lieu avec le
Parti socialiste mais il n'y aura pas de
consigne de vote pour le deuxème tour
pour une partie du mouvement c'est le
gage la maturité pour l'autre parti
c'est la déception nous avions aussi
quand même une très grande méfiance des
structures politiques c'est sans doute
68 alors j'avais développé pour moi-même
une théorie la théorie du gardien de but
la règle du jeu c'est que personne de
face de la politique sauf le gardien de
but qui était là pour empêcher
précisément
euh l'alourdissement ou la coagulation
je sais pas comment on pourrait appeler
ça la cristallisation d'un parti
politique qui aurait créé immédiatement
ses clairs ses bureaucrates et ses
dirigeants et donc j'étais le gardien de
but alors évidemment j'avais le droit
moi de faire de la politique et les
autres ne devaient pas en faire mais
c'était précisément pour interdire et
empêcher la formation de toute
bureaucratie verte ça a duré 10 ans
quand
même 5 4 3 2 1 François mitteran est élu
président de la
République nous répétons donc estimation
c2ionbll Monsieur François mitteran est
élu président de la République
51,7 % Valérie giscardestin
48,3%. à plus de 60 % les voix des
écologistes sont reporté sur François
mitteran élu le 10 mai 1981 il met fin à
23 ans de pouvoir de droite pour toute
une génération c'est l'espoir de voir
émerger une autre manière de gouverner
devoir s'ouvrir le débat sur le
nucléaire le 3 juin 1981 le gouvernement
renonce à la centrale de plogof et à
l'extension du camp sur le Larzac mais
il conserve l'orientation énergétique
nucléaire après le cri d'alarme les
écologistes acceptent le jeu du pouvoir
commence les années de
gestion
[Musique]
à th
th